one of the top prospects in all the land
one of the best quarterbacks available
in this year's draft he is from UCLA
Josh Rosen good to see you sir
absolutely thanks for having me on you
appreciate it I know you don't do this a
lot so I appreciate it if not too much
how many how many uh this is the first
one I've ever been in studio the studio
is awesome fantastic it's so cool I
appreciate my green over here are you a
golfer you play uh no but I try I have
fun let me get out there no come on now
that's that's what elite elite
quarterbacks must play golf yeah so
Aaron Rodgers actually came down and was
hanging out with us for a little bit at
the athletes first clastic our agencies
okay a golf tournament and I shot in the
90s had fun out there had one whom I've
had two birdies first ever okay and
think Aaron ripped out of 70 and I told
him that I was okay I got the got out
there had fun shot a 96 97 and easily
yeah looks at me with the dead straight
face and goes that's gonna have to get
better yeah you're gonna need to get
better that one yeah because I mean if
you're gonna join that elite quarterback
group you can't just let's put it this
way you can't have a kicker and I've
loved kickers you can't have a kicker go
out and beat you in golf I would record
it back out agree with right I mean but
you're more you're a tennis guy though
right yeah what was the last time that
you played tennis um you know me and
coach fish actually coached fish jet
fish my I saw coordinates all I met
staples last night as a matter of fact
okay that's Michigan Wolverine roots
yeah well I saw him there yes so he's a
big tennis player and we've been meaning
to get on the course getting on the
court yeah and and play and haven't
haven't gotten to it yet so if you had
to tell me Josh Rosen your game your
tennis game is like fill in the blank
whose tennis game was your I was a big
Patrick rafter Pete Sampras fan big
serve and volleyer okay I didn't mess
with the whole ground stroke they just
wanted to get to the net and the point
right because you're so I mean you could
cover the the net I mean you'd be up
there what are you six four right yeah
okay yeah so I when I played younger
then the last time I really picked it up
and played for it was probably in high
school just wanted to pick it up and
have fun fun and season
think like my sophomore year
and the last time I played before that I
was like 3-4 inches shorter so you see
the whole court you can serve all
different kinds of angles get to the net
and cover the court a lot better than
you were could when you're like 13 okay
so let's stop talking tennis because I
don't want you to get a downgrade by
anybody that's sitting out there
thinking you're not as into football as
you need to be you hearing that a lot
yeah I mean I think up until this point
it hasn't really bothered me but if my
thing was basically one of the combine
and meeting all these teams personally
if any of these rumors and stuff
persisted after this point then it might
bother me a little bit but I I'm not
gonna worry about people judging me that
don't know me I think if people actually
did get to know me and continue to say
those things and it bothered me a little
bit but I think I've put my best my best
foot out first at the combine at these
at these interviews at my pro day and I
think that moving forward seems really
going to know what the real Josh Rosen
is all about where do you think the the
rumors come from you know I don't really
know I mean I was thrown in the
spotlight really early at 18 years old
had three full years of it at UCLA and
guys picking and prodding every single
thing you do I didn't really get any
time to sit back and look at like a
Brett Hundley a year ahead of me and
kind of diagnose and sit and say who do
I want to be when this spotlight comes
and I didn't I didn't get that they just
you get thrown out there and I think the
the West Coast and Southern California
in particular saw me grow up and become
become Who I am today live we're live
live on TV we're live on TV on radio I
mean you know it's a simulcast yeah yeah
don't want to shun them but uh yes I
mean basically they saw me grow up I
made some mistakes and but I'm glad I
made those mistakes it's an opportunity
to grow and become man that I am today
Josh Rosen here in the Rich Eisen show
what what other mistakes
what was your identified estates you
made I've never broken the law or done
anything with real real substantial
legal consequences like that I've I was
just I was a kid I did some stupid
things I put a hot tub in my dorm room
yeah
I made you a legend yeah I think the
lessons with all these things the the f
Trump out on the golf course is is
there's a time in place I mean I'm not
gonna change who I am on the inside I'm
gonna be me but you just you have to
understand your audience you have to
understand who you're talking to there's
a time and place for everything that
they're trying to trim the fat a little
bit that's the expression I'm using off
the message but still stay on message
what about being coachable Josh that's
been a question about you that you're
that you're gonna be the guy who always
asks why instead of saying okay yeah so
I mean I don't have that four or five
speed to just take off I don't really
have a get hit a jail free card like
that so my thing is I'm gonna get to the
line of scrimmage and I want to know I
want to have runs through every single
possible situation and scenario in my
head before I snap the ball just to make
sure that regardless of what happens
there's always something to do and
somewhere to go I want to know the
inside and outside of every play I want
to be my offensive coordinators head on
the field and in terms of like whether
coach ability and what I think I'm not
gonna speak to my own character Who I am
but I think you just have to talk to my
old coaches I think it'll vouch for me
very strongly I mean I've had a
documented pass with Trent Dilfer but I
think we've gotten along incredibly well
up to this point now and I think to get
onto that aspect I think you just got to
talk to people who know me now we've had
Trent on the show and he said the same
thing that the two of you did not see
eye to eye get along or you didn't
really want to receive coaching from him
is the way I perceived it not that might
be my perception but he said he's done a
complete 180 on you with you and he even
said to you you know I mean in effect
you know hey I'm I'm sorry it didn't
work out at the very beginning you're
nodding your head would you agree with
that you know I don't think I just don't
think we got enough time together I
think when if you want to get into the
Nitty Gritty and get into a real deep
relationship with someone and understand
how it works I mean if you have an
office coordinator head coach you're
going through even if you're only with
someone for a year I had three
coordinators for a year but you you get
to know them the elite eleven we hung
out in Portland I you don't really get
to know each other very well and I think
maybe we just kind of didn't mesh very
well at first but I'm
we got to know each other better after
that we spent more time together and I
think he really understood Who I am and
I really got to understand him and I
think I relationships a lot stronger
because of it one more thing that I want
to hit on with you that I've heard as a
narrative about your prospects in the
NFL that is a so-called red flag and
that is that you come from a family of
means and that you in the NFL won't be
as diehard of a professional or try as
hard as you possibly can because you've
got a fallback position in life how do
you respond to something like that you
know I think this this thing is kind of
blown up I mean there are if anything I
think that would show my real love for
the game is that I don't I don't
actually need it I'm voluntarily putting
my entire I dropped out of school I had
to convince my parents to drop out of
college to pursue this full-time I want
to I want to be great at this I didn't
want to that's basically why I'm
becoming a professional I wanted to put
all of my time into this and see how
good I could really be and the fact that
I don't actually need this I think
actually shows the true passion that I
have for this game I mean I love this
game I gave up tennis for it because I
crave the team atmosphere I wanted to to
be involved in something bigger than
yourself in tennis or golf you have fans
that are that are rooting for you as a
person whereas it's it's cool to be
attached to something bigger
I mean you throw a touchdown at the rose
you throw a touchdown at the Rose Bowl
and you can turn your sidelines and and
see 120 of your immediate best friends
that you're like affecting their lives
in a positive way directly you're
looking at administration coaches fans
that you're you're making their day and
I think that's that's what gets me going
about football footballs is the ultimate
team sport the better team doesn't
always win it's not a basketball
best-of-seven series it's it's it's one
game anything can happen and I think
it's a really cool relationship you have
with your with your teammates and your
coaches too to go out there and
basically let it rip and see how it goes
so you've never been in a huddle Josh
Rosen third and one game
the line clock ticking down look your
teammates in the face and say let's
execute if we don't huh my dad's got a
401k that's never happened no my dad's
got a 401k on to break I mean since ooh
me when I hear that and all honestly I
think what in the hell's the matter with
people in the NFL if they say the kid
has other interests the kid has a head
on his shoulders the kid comes from
means so he's not gonna want it as much
as somebody who doesn't that makes zero
I mean there are tons of people in
professional football currently that
don't eat it I'm just I'm just okay to
say something about it and say that some
people play this game because we love
this game not because it's it's our
paycheck to to provide for our families
and that's why I think I'm in a unique
position to where I can maybe I can I'd
said things in college and moving
forwards will will will say and do
things for the betterment of society and
people in general not just to ensure my
paycheck okay Josh Rosen here on the
Rich Eisen show I want to take a break
come back and start looking under the
hood here as to who's already contacted
you who you've worked out for whether
you wore a hat thrown in the rain like
some other quarterbacks in this town did
which to me as a bald man is a red flag
red flag it's a red flag I mean if you
have a leak quarterback hair that things
you skip just don't get wet just just
ball captain long-sleeve shirt right I
mean what are you doing right okay Josh
Rosen is here we'll check on that and
start bench cut as a game we play here
where we gave you three choices you have
to start one you have to bench what you
have to cut one we have some good ones
for you
looking forward to it are you really yes
is that what you said is that what you
said to coaches when they're when they
said to you at the combine we're gonna
put you on the board but I actually mean
it this time Josh Rosen is here on the
Rich Eisen show gonna take a break and
be back with Josh in a moment
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show Josh
Rosen hanging with us here while Josh
Allen is going through his pro day right
now right in Wyoming is that happening
that's true yes okay so convergence of
Josh's we got one here in person and and
Josh where's he is he throwing we have
breaking news on Josh out at the pro day
which is so you know Sam Darnell threw
in the rain Josh worked out in the rain
of his yes Josh Allen throwing indoors
today red flag red far off red flags
everywhere take them off the board red
flags everywhere Josh now white shoes
the red flat so I gotta ask and again I
know that you're you're you're you're
all part of the same quarterback class
and that you're all sort of brothers in
arms as well
Sam Donald thrown in the rain and a ball
cap red flag or no red flag I can't
comment on that because actually I have
a little bit more hair okay so I think
that might be now yesterday did you
throw in the rain yesterday yes okay
did you wear a ball cap no I did not
there you go
first overall pick what more do you need
to know when they ask what's the
difference between darn old and Rosen's
ball cap I mean long sleeve shirt or
short sleeve shirt yeah uh short sleeves
yes III do wear long sleeves I am a long
sleeve guy but you won't I think in the
rain sometimes you gotta just embrace
the element okay just take it in right
yeah well that's what Donald said that
was the the story that came out of his
pro day is that USC was gonna try and
make sure he gets out on the field when
it wasn't raining he's like no me out
there you know I mean we all the
tremendous respect for each other I know
you do yeah well what was it like at the
combine with everybody meet never Sam
was actually my roommate we had a great
time at the combo yeah okay that's
amazing so what was you like does he
snore no I was I was scared I would
snore but he said I was okay okay so
that's good um everybody said no no red
flag on the snoring yeah any red flags
is a roommate any roommate Redflex
Donal I think we're a little suspicious
of one another maybe like disconnecting
someone's alarm
but none of that happened well showed up
everywhere on time that's amazing so you
and did you know that going in or did
you just unpack your belongings and
their Sam Donald who's unpacking his
belonging there's Sam really yeah you
weren't even you don't even get a
heads-up I mean darn 'old and Rosen I
don't think a very close alphabetic
they're not at all it's what they trying
to mess with you is that another combine
trying to mess with somebody's head
situation I don't think it mess with us
I think we just I mean I'm it was almost
I I liked it having a roommate that
actually knew and could hang on how do
you know Darnell just by playing against
him yes all the quarterbacks get kind of
know each other the process from the
high school recruiting to whatever
college camps the Manning Academy I mean
I got really close with Baker two years
ago at the man Academy and known Sam
being from Southern California and Josh
Allen met at the NC double-a symposium
over in Annapolis actually last year
while the combine was going on so I mean
we're all shooting each other good luck
texts before games it's all it's all
family we're all we're all friendly I
mean no one's rooting bad for anyone
else we just might be rooting a little
better for snow I know that I'm having
I'm having a little bit of fun with it
so let's get into Josh Rosen who you you
worked out for the Jets yesterday that
true yes okay who else have you worked
out privately for yeah I guess I guess
that removes the the private aspect of
it rabbit work out who have you worked
out personally bills Browns Jets and
Giants what you get from the Giants away
from that one awesome awesome people
love to go to dinner the night before
work out the next morning
had a great time got along with most
every team every team that came it's
really cool and the owners come in you
got to get to meet them and talk to some
unbelievably successful successful
people and it's just a really fun
experience so Steve Tisch picked up
dinner uh he picked up the deed picked
up the check yeah was Mara there too was
Jon memmer there too so you met both
owners of the New York Giants yeah
number two overall how did you how did
you find out that the Jets had traded up
Instagram okay in social media yeah you
know they pulled the trigger the day
after
personally I balling you at your protei
do you think there's any connection
there you know I don't know I think
that's your job to make those yes
there's a connection make those
connections
okay so you've worked out or do you have
any anything else planned for you to go
visit anybody right now yes so I leave
on 3rd and going around the country
meeting a bunch of teams from the 3rd to
14th drop some names please
it's ok we're all gonna find out all
those teams that I worked out for then
Broncos Cardinals Dolphins on that list
yeah I think so yeah ok I'm gonna hang
out the doll feet a little bit
yes well does that look well and and
Marino at the combine I was really cool
shake their hand you just I yeah who was
your guy growing up um Peyton Peyton was
my god Marvin Harrison Reggie Wayne days
those were those were own beliefs you
were rooting for the Colts when you were
yeah absolutely because of 18 yeah he
was the man and you've been at his
Academy in his camp yeah what was that
like for you it was awesome it was
really I mean I don't like to be a man
of cliches but it is a good dream come
true
that camp was awesome I mean especially
because as an Eagles fan growing up one
of the first games I got to see was the
Eagles Patriots Super Bowl and from that
point on I was I was in a photograph
review with the Eagles gear on and by
the way a very nice scarf that's where
it looks like you're a Southern
Californian right there that's actually
outside of Carlo's Bakery in Hoboken New
Jersey yeah
so they based on you being a Southern
California in the way you're dressed
fifty degrees degrees out because I'm
looking at the others around wearing
hardly anything on what do you think it
could be sixty but as shady okay so
you're an Eagles fan growing up and yeah
so I was not a Patriots fan as the one
of the first games I saw
was in Jacksonville Florida yeah bTW my
Eagle so along the the Manning theme I
was brooding I know the Giants are not
ideal and ideal team as an Eagles fan
but I just wasn't a Patriots guy because
of that game and I was rooting for Eli
and the Giants vigorously in those two
Super Bowls vigorously they say you keep
using words like that amongst your red
flag job should be very honest with you
we want to make sure that your draft
stock is better than when you walked in
the room so I want to play start bench
cut with you okay okay that's a Rich
Eisen show staple Josh Rosen here on the
Rich Eisen show headed please let's
start with best Los Angeles fast food
let's start with that you got to start
one you got a bench one you've got to
cut one okay okay
Pink's hot dogs in and out burger or fat
burger start bench starting in and out
each and every day of the week it's it's
a it's a first-ballot Hall of Famer
yeah absolutely okay I'll bench fat
burger cut Pink's
not really okay red flag not a hot dog
guy you play in New York Coney Island
you know Nathan's yeah well I mean you
know right you'll figure out what your
terrain is I mean is there Shake Shack
you might like an East Coast dog better
than a West don't know that answer for
everything there you go by the way it
doesn't want to go to West Coast offense
team you just hug right there that's a
red flag red flag reason reading
everything and okay here we go class
you'd most likely cut okay start bench
cut Josh Rosen class you'd what you just
would refer not to go to math science or
English start science bench math mmm-hmm
cut English but I was an English major
in college
so she was much so she would sincerely
cut them she would protest vigorously
protest let's keep keep going with the
music right here okay favorite interest
favorite interest for Josh Rosen stark
bench cut here are the three choices for
ball tennis speaking your mind start
bench cut huh interesting he's
processing I'm asking why in my head
right now
[Laughter]
there you are by the way in a football
uniform and a tennis by the way nice
nice kids on Steve Whitehead support
there go and there you are speaking your
mind favorite interest football tennis
speaking your mind start bench gun um I
think I'd start football bench tennis
cut speaking your mind but I'd cut it
because I don't think it ever goes away
I think you are who you are you're not
gonna be able to take away what makes
you you family feared good answer
clapping answer good answer I love that
last one start bench cut here we go Josh
Rosen cities you'd like to live in whoa
Denver New York or Cleveland his agent
is nodding his head no vociferously
vigorously Denver New York Cleveland I
think this is a question you have to ask
the GMs I think that you gotta ask them
if they're gonna start venture cut me
Ryan's fired up good answer oh let you
off the hook avenge death
this has been fun coming at a great time
oh I appreciate that can I take the mug
with me is yours to keep
we got from the Rose Bowl Legacy
Foundation we got to old Rose Bowl seats
that we have now made part of the Rich
Eisen show studio that's right behind
Chris Brockman from the 70s if you
wouldn't mind putting your Josh Rosen on
that absolutely you'll get that so
that'll be a nice new keepsake for us
good luck to you sir good luck to you as
you know I watched you on the combine
spin it on Shabbos I dropped that ring
the coverage your dad caught that yeah
my dad my dad did catch that and put two
enthusiastic thumbs up vociferous thumbs
up vigorously through the subside
vigorously through so good luck thank
you please don't be stranger come back
here
time you're welcome here anytime
absolutely bet that's Josh Rosen heading
off to points unknown but as Larry David
said on behalf of Jets fans he wants
them to draft the [ __ ] what he said Josh
Rosen here on the Rich Eisen show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience